another two british citizens captured by
russian forces charged with being
mercenaries
22 year old dylan healey from
cambridgeshire was reportedly working as
an aid volunteer when he was seized with
another british citizen
thirty-five-year-old andrew hill from
plymouth understood to be a father of
four and a former british soldier was in
ukraine volunteering with the military
they were both arrested in april and are
being held in the so-called donetsk
people's republic a breakaway region in
eastern ukraine that's been fighting
ukrainian forces since 2014.
stanislav
was held by the same group for two and a
half years until he was released in a
prisoner swap in 2019.
he refers to the prison he was at as a
concentration camp
i was in in israel for 28 months so
all i see is a torture for every day not
only for me it's only for it's also for
for women
for women in the last and and men and it
was
it was terrible were you tortured yes i
am electricity
mr healy and mr hill are facing the same
mercenary charges as aiden aslan and
sean pinner who were sentenced to the
death penalty in june
sky news met the two british men in the
trenches before their arrests they'd
been living in ukraine and maintained
they were legitimately serving with the
country's military
stanislav
warns the british government to take
this threat of their death sentence
seriously
they can execute them now this is a real
threat to show great britain that russia
has no boundaries in relation to your
country this is a real threat it must be
understood
the foreign office has said we condemn
the exploitation of prisoners of war and
civilians for political purposes and
have raised this issue with russia we
are in constant contact with the
government of ukraine on their cases and
are fully supportive of ukraine in its
efforts to get them released
it's understood up to a hundred foreign
nationals have been taking prisoner in
this war so far
but one organization working in aid in
ukraine
says the arrests of british citizens are
being far more widely publicized
this tactic has been mainly used for
british prisoners we are aware that
there has been some
americans
ex-american soldiers picked up
in um in similar regions um and aren't
being publicly shown on this so it's
it's quite um interesting that it's
mostly british
prisoners that have been uh being used
in this way it's showing that russia is
a
seeing britain as a big ally to ukraine
and this and therefore using british
prisoners as a way of
maybe negotiating but also using very
political tools
earlier this week ukraine announced the
largest exchange of prisoners of war
since russia invaded securing the
release of 144 of its soldiers
it seems there's far more political
capital in holding british prisoners and
there's great concern over their fate
sally lockwood sky news keeve